Vindication for Elon Musk the
billionaire using the social media
platform he now owns to celebrate
thank goodness the wisdom of the people
has prevailed I am deeply appreciative
of the jury's unanimous finding of
innocence in the Tesla 420 take private
case
the world's second richest had testified
for eight hours on the witness stand
defending his motives for this tweet
four years ago
I am considering taking Tesla private at
420 funding secured
the tweets sent Tesla shares soaring but
when the buyout failed to materialize
the share price fell back to Earth that
resulted in a class action from
investors who calculated their losses as
high as 12 billion dollars
we're disappointed we're examining
options
the troll comes at a sensitive time for
musk whose dominated headlines for his
chaotic takeover of Twitter
umikulsum Sharif al-jazeera